hey guys I'm thrilled to announce our
new channel cinema songs check out this
preview of our first episode this week
we're honoring Jurassic Park I've always
had a thing for the scary movies like
the bad acting maybe see some boobies
watching hostile helps me bother soup on
a first date watching Human Centipede I
watch The Exorcist and let the whole
time tilt through the shining old Jack
and his perm all my friends would look
at me terrified I ain't never been
scared it was a source of pride then one
fine day hang you with my crew my homey
said I want to show you something new as
we watch felt something I never felt
before nothing scares me quite like the
bus
fraid of a serial killer but you won't
catch me watching the true acid brother
jaws is why so if you like that go to
the cinema songs channel and watch the
full video don't forget to Like and
subscribe
does but ain't nothing worse than bobasa
Raptors